how's it going my name is I don't
remember having these laser sight but
anyway me and barrel I gotta finish this
story we came from that I think so
[ __ ] my Mouse's Arkansas all right let's
go in here better he's been oh yeah he's
survived the explosion Billy don't do it
you will die barrel what the [ __ ] barrel
what the [ __ ] you like in here better ha
ha
are you coming with me if I'm dying
you're dying with me [ __ ] oh [ __ ] get
away from it
okay what I'm not doing anything
whoa barrel look what the hell what the
hell what the hell
mouse stop controlling me
what the [ __ ] well what are you going on
watch
Bogey's don't jani my way back huh huh
don't run
alright Baroness dance the engine thank
God I thank God but Alice's [ __ ] dance
well love it's not hmm what's it called
expect
well that was get so dang it was really
good custom story I think I will start a
new one right away
[Music]
I know he's working on new one also
I know I am kind of harsh with cousin
sometimes if I'm not enjoying playing it
I'm kind of open with it but I really
overall experience of this always really
good even though some parts maybe it
wasn't so rich it's easier to criticize
then give positive feedback but I do
want to give him some positive feedback
cuz it was a really good constant story
and I think in the next one who improve
even more so I'm definitely look for
with it for that but anyway let's AB
that's I think I will continue tender
breeze lake we'll see in a second I'm
gonna snap my finger I don't know why Oh
[Music]
how's the gun bruh oh my name we are
back with the [ __ ] spider
what are you doing spider Wow whoa what
out I haven't even started baby you
better try to save me with save that
come here penny come here pity I shaved
for you spiders man what's up ah okay
oh god I don't want to go in here
alright how's it going Meryl alright I'm
[ __ ] bad don't think I can make it a
trick what box them ride my head sounds
like your spiders faffing I swear to god
stop tapping spider
it's [ __ ] nasty stop Mattia [ __ ]
spider-man spider-man Oh what are you
doing yeah [ __ ] oh he's trying to
tell me to go over here aren't you
barrel maybe it's trying to help me
I mean there's a lot of stuff here I
don't trust it
alright it's gotta be some deep thing
this is a pot no I can pick it out back
okay let's read this but before I want
to say the reason why I continue this if
it's kids look really well it was just
not their words it's been patched now
and I think I will enjoy it a lot more
let's just say that I recently is my
experiment with the liquid acid I found
like we can gradually gain the liquid as
it just by mixing water chemicals
torturing people I don't think my latest
project will they can please come winder
Maryland the barrels I like I like that
[ __ ] a seadoo aqua okay accident aqua
let's go and get some of that [ __ ] or
the meat I guess that means we gotta go
to the liver part of this storage
which is definitely not good from I
guess what's down there what is that a
sweater and pair it on it
maybe someone was doing an abortion
there you can never know these things
oh yeah ever since I stopped playing is
so many people somebody for us kept
saying oh you know to keep playing it's
super scary should I just jump down or
just just what should I do
no I don't think I should just jump down
and saying oh it will get scary you've
gotta keep playing I think it's already
kind of scary but yeah
keep playing now boys all right I'm not
wasting my lining this is really like
say I updated
I tried this other one I haven't tried
it yet but I made a bunch of [ __ ] and it
did something wrong so he replaced all
the files I mean that's not good all
right let's check this sweater out oh
it's a dress
well it's assuming that I remember this
game it looked like they were violent
all right
abortion rape it's not a good good thing
are the stones crying identified stop
crying all right we can never stay
together that's how it is I just have to
be a little all right so did I just come
back the same holy [ __ ] a lot of
Jamarcus why the [ __ ] am I supposed to
go now I remember why I stopped I kept
running around in a vagina
and kept burning around not knowing what
the [ __ ] I'm doing
and the mementos never tell you either
lower part of the oh hello I'll I'll
back you up thank you very much
hope we keep them there what the [ __ ]
all right let's go back again yeah
[ __ ] spikes speeder there's no
Stefano either that's gonna help
well maybe one of these doors
how about this one gobbling some wood
shower cap Lincoln barrel I don't know
what it's called English I'm sorry sorry
[Music]
wearing this [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
scared me I didn't expect that
[Music]
not a dust ya back how many time that I
had to tell you there was nothing in
there was it yes sanim [ __ ]
what about over here what about over
here what bad news the stone rock come
on laughing for dipping their penis in
oil we've been through this before
battles actually no having dungeon
entrance I guess that's why I came from
yep this is why I stopped playing cuz I
have no idea where the [ __ ] to go I
would appreciate it if they told me a
little end I know love a part of the
storage but I don't even know where a
storage is this could be the storage
I'm just sayin what about this
are you a storage this is why we came
from being don't be [ __ ]
I'm sorry myself come on what am I doing
with my life
why is this happening to me see this
this could be a storage it's just to
find a dream okay and find a gym but
that's okay they were probably more
pointless rooms in your night you just
have to be a little bit what is this
this looks like a lower part of storage
oh well you wouldn't leave the miters
alone
alright fine wrong with the miners and
taking mine cut pants
they're not exactly volunteer yeah
exactly nah [ __ ] miners after it this is
actually kind of creepy I'm glad you're
with me lantern you weren't here right
now I had no one to cuddle with Bob why
so many [ __ ] barrels all right what
am I supposed to go there how about in
this is a Jacke Wow life but walking
shadow a poor player that struts and
frets ISM and our time to read
how come someone in here
what is going on here what is this place
what is this give me that [ __ ]
what [ __ ] all right this is the progress
I guess frog guy gets
all right so I guess I take the waterway
no can't go down the waterfall how do I
get up there huh can't jump either why
can I jump
what's wrong with jumping these days
something beneath here that I need I
supposed to use a box to take it up
there
so annoying those puzzle I can't jump
come on what if I let me jump Butte Oh
No there's nothing there
why what the [ __ ] they're ladder here
there's nothing nothing but nothing yeah
I guess
fine I'll just build my way up there I
don't care Caracara but I don't think
this is a right way I see something down
there what do we have here barrels why
do you always try to hide [ __ ] from me
what did I ever do that
this is gonna fall please don't fall
believe down just stay with me and I'll
treat you right because tonight it's all
about loving each other it's all about
giving each other
Brad sweet tender loving tonight I ran
that a man Latin because that was
singing this stupid song instead of
focusing that mile and you were drowning
out oh you need to fit down to fill down
on Mouse jumping down enough enough
enough I'm at the save all right
yes yes you think you can stop me game
you think you can stop me do you think
if you got me good Oh what is this
I pulled you just like I pull nothing
and a jump and a son of a [ __ ] and a
teleporter so if you jump down you die
from a I mean from another [ __ ] try our
damn [ __ ] [ __ ] jump is impossible
alright oh I gotta make it before the
elevator come on where are we where are
we mommy where are we gotta focus on
this jump I landed here but like very
enjoyed it's gotta come today and I'll
see you next episode of why am i me
[Music]
Barney yeah what I can see you'd
understand why I want you sure -
friendly right now